[Music]
demi lovato goes full punk rock in their
new music video for substance
demi sports short jet black hair with
bangs and channels their inner rock star
smashing framed records with a baseball
bat demi's friends also graffiti walls
make a mess with food served by a
demi-look-alike drag queen and have a
pillow fight i had fun and to get this
there's even a special celebrity cameo
from demi's friend paris hilton
[Music]
the pals sit on a motorcycle paris
looking edgy and all black as they light
some dynamite that's what's up but
lovatics know this isn't the first time
paris has popped up in a demivid
[Music]
baby yep that is paris in 2017 dancing
in demi's sorry not sorry video but back
to demi's latest single
[Music]
they performed the track for the first
time on jimmy kimmel live
[Music]
demi even brought their look from the
music video to the late night stage
which may not have been the plan earlier
in the week nobody's gonna know nobody's
gonna know they're gonna know
yeah that's the singer on tick tock
wednesday sporting a pixie cut without
bangs revealing they got a nasty gash on
their forehead just hours before
appearing on kimmel how would they know
seems like demi got resourceful and a
wig did the trick though demi went into
detail about what led to a need for
banks apparently their passion for
crystals took an unexpectedly dangerous
turn i went to bend down to pick
something up and i didn't see the
amethyst and i hit my head
and i had to get three stitches last
night
in my face wow and i called my doctor
and i was like hey i just hit my face
do i need stitches and he was like
facetime me so
we facetimed and i was like i have
kimmel tomorrow
like what do i do so i did what any sane
person would do and made a tick tock
before i even told me of course at least
demi seems to be a good sport about the
injury but i'm totally clumsy
in the meantime we'll be safely head
banging to demi's new song and avoiding
any crystals
[Music]
[Music]
you